[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale en quelques minutes voici les
titres de ce jeudi 9 septembre
la visite ce matin de sophie cluzel sur
le territoire la secrétaire d'état
chargé des personnes handicapées s'est
rendu à l'école des mesnuls et dans le
lycée de la queue-lez-yvelines ces deux
établissements porte un projet
pédagogique sur l'école inclusive
les candidatures pour le concours
créatrice d'avenir sont ouvertes
jusqu'au 30 septembre il a pour but
d'accompagner de donner un coup de pouce
aux femmes entrepreneures
d'ile-de-france dans ce journal retour
d'expérience avec sophie forme aux
lauréates en 2020 céline leroux
d'initiative 78 sera également avec nous
en plateau pour présenter la 11e édition
et puis à la fin de ce journal rencontre
avec camille lacourt le multiple
champion du monde de natation était
l'invitée d'yves in business club le
réseau de dirigeants et de décideurs
c'est est au golf de la boulie à
versailles nous avons de développer ces
titres est direction trappe pour débuter
ce journal ou le 18 août dernier le
conseil d'état annulé l'élection
municipale de 2020 la ville n'a donc
plus de mer ni d'élus une délégation
spéciale a été nommé par le préfet pour
s'occuper des affaires courantes dans la
commune est les détails dans ce sujet de
mélanie poké de bixente mais rien senti
steban
plus de conseil municipal mais une
mairie toujours dirigé depuis
l'annulation de l'élection par le
conseil d'état en août la ville de
trappes est gérée par une délégation
spéciale autonome une délégation
spéciale est composée pour une commune
de moins de trente cinq mille habitants
de 3,3 membres une traditionnellement
parce que ça nous arrive assez souvent
de nommer des délégations spéciales nous
prenons un ancien élu ancien maire en
général accompagnées de
fonctionnaires souvent à la retraite et
qui ont l'habitude de travailler avec
les collectivités pour trappe la
commission est composée de michel pons
ancien maire de villennes-sur-seine
christian nicolet directeur de
préfecture à la retraite et gilles
croissant premier vice président du
tribunal judiciaire de versailles
objectif de la délégation spéciale c'est
de faire fonctionner la mairie et les
services communaux pendant cette période
et bien il y à des mariages qui doivent
être prononcés il y a tout un travail
administratif qui doit continuer on peut
pas se permettre une interruption
notamment du service public ce qui
serait défavorable évidemment aux
administrés est la délégation est aussi
chargée de préparer les élections
municipales partielles les scrutins
auront lieu les dimanches 10 et 17
octobre prochains cinq candidats sont
pour le moment déclaré
dans l'actualité le baromètre de
l'immobilier publiés ce jeudi par nos
confrères du parisien principal
enseignement à retenir en ile-de-france
la grande couronne francilienne attire
de plus en plus les acquéreurs après les
différents confinement dans les yvelines
en un an les prix ont grimpé de 4,3 pour
cent maisons et appartements confondues
certaines villes enregistrent de fortes
hausses +6 7% pour les maisons à
montesson et les appartements à verneuil
sur seine en cinq ans du côté de chatou
les prix des maisons ont augmenté de 18%
la nouvelle a été officialisée au milieu
de l'été le multiplex ne verra pas le
jour à maurepas un site de huit salles
de cinéma étaient prévus sur place une
première pierre avait même été posée
symboliquement novembre 2018 mais la
crise sanitaire a fini par enterrer
définitivement le projet antoine durand
et patrick jacques de dixmude 1
le projet lancé en 2009 aux abords du
village de loisirs ne verra finalement
jamais le jour c'est ce qu'a dévoilé
nout france le propriétaire du terrain
dans un communiqué début août le
chantier était déjà à l'arrêt depuis de
longs mois en raison de difficultés au
niveau des devis la crise sanitaire a
fini d'enterrer le projet cette crise
sanitaire a affecté tout le secteur
culturel comme on le sait aussi donc
l'activité cinématographique et ans
conjointement entre les deux sociétés
ils ont préféré abandonner ce projet le
complexe devait être composée de huit
salles
et aurait dû accueillir entre 450 milles
et 500 mille spectateurs par an un
véritable manque à gagner pour les
commerçants des alentours mais les
différents acteurs du projet ne compte
pas en rester là nous sommes encore trop
tôt pour savoir ce qui va se passer une
chose est sûre nous savons que nous de
france partenaire va nous proposer des
projets nous allons les étudier pour le
bien en fin de compte de notre ville
démord pas y 1 et de notre nos
commerçants au village des loisirs
reste désormais à attendre l'annoncé
d'un futur projet sur cette parcelle
à suivre dans un instant à la visite de
sophie cluzel le reportage revenant sur
cette visite au minul et à la
queue-lez-yvelines 1 ce sera à suivre
dans ce journal dont on va parler à
d'abord d'entrepreneuriat avec plus
précisément une thématique
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin qui a son
concours créatrice d'avenir est lancé
pour une onzième édition les
candidatures sont ouvertes jusqu'au 30
septembre et à la clé un accompagnement
et une dotation pour les lauréates on en
parle avec céline leroux bonsoir concert
qu'il est la responsable d'initiative 78
c'est l'antenne départementale
d'initiative ile de france qui est à
l'origine du concours comment se porte
avant de parler de ce concours
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin en
ile-de-france est ce que la création
d'entreprise les reprises d'entreprises
ont pu se poursuivre en 2021 malgré le
contexte sanitaire oui tout à fait la
création et la reprise d'entreprise et
plus particulièrement d'ailleurs la
reprise d'entreprise a vraiment
continuer il ya une vraie dynamique là
qui est reparti depuis septembre voilà
c'est pas forcément féminin après la
part féminine continue d'augmenter on a
à peu près à 40% de femmes aujourd'hui
qui crée une entreprise donc voilà on
est loin des premiers clichés qui
pouvaient exister il ya quelques années
avec voilà un stéréotype masculin et
pour les entreprises qui existait déjà
elles ont plus l ont pu maintenir leur
activité c'est haché où il ya une étude
qui a été menée donc pendant la période
du coc vide les 71% des femmes voilà
sont plutôt enfin pense pouvoir
maintenir leurs activités malgré la
crise se sont réinventés elles ont
innové voilà alors remodeler leur
business model pour pouvoir s'adapter à
cette crise vous lui dites malgré la
crise puisqu'on imagine bien qu'il ya un
vrai impact de cette crise sanitaire qui
est dernier ensuite une crise économique
tout à fait où il ya certains secteurs
qui ont été très touché plus
particulièrement que d'autres notamment
le transport la restauration
les loisirs le sport voilà qui font
partie des secteurs qui ont été
fortement touchés et du coup c'est plus
compliqué pour ces entreprises là de
passer cette crise mais à créatrice
d'avenir prend encore plus d'importance
en ce moment même si c'est la onzième
édition de ce concours est aussi présent
depuis de nombreuses années un coup de
pouce peut aider en cette période c'est
quoi déjà les objectifs de créatrice
d'avenir je le rappelle un onzième
édition cette année de ce concours alors
les principaux objectifs sont de
sensibilisation de sensibiliser les
femmes à la création d'entreprises de
les valoriser de montrer que voilà même
en tant que femme on peut créer une
entreprise n'y a pas de profil type est
que c'est pas que des hommes qui peuvent
créer une entreprise et qu'on peut créer
aussi dans tous secteurs confondus donc
ça permet derrière de mettre en valeur
des parcours de donner envie à la de la
création d'entreprises de les
accompagner de les aider a aussi apporté
des fois des aides financières notamment
par le réseau initiative qui fait
notamment comme activité principale du
prêt d'honneur à la création
d'entreprise donc ça peut être aussi
également par le biais du concours de
dotation financière et de dotation on va
dire plus d'accompagnement voilà
pratico-pratique nous les accompagner ça
ne s'adresse pas qu'aux femmes et la
création d'entreprise c'est un challenge
particulier pour se lancer dans la
création d'entreprise il vaut mieux être
accompagné c'est quelque chose dont il
est difficile de se lancer seul dans
lequel il ait personne tout à fait oui
le principal la preuve principale chose
enfin en création d'entreprise c'est de
se faire accompagner se faire entourer
et les chiffres le montrent une
entreprise qui a été accompagné à
beaucoup plus chances de pérennité une
entreprise qui n'a pas été accompagnée
pour initiative une entreprise qui a été
même financé par le réseau à 94% chance
d'exister encore après trois ans contre
66% en moyenne nationale fait rien venir
ça s'adresse ce qui alors ça s'adresse à
des femmes qui ont créé leur entreprise
ou qui vont créer à la fin de la date du
concours la quille et du 30 septembre
2021 qui sont majoritaires dans leurs
structures et qu'ils soient implantés
sur la région ile de france est donc à
la clé je le disais en préambule il ya
un programme d'accompagnement de
financement et aussi de valorisation de
ces femmes entrepreneures et déjà il y
as il aurait attendant dans ce concours
qui sont nommés dans différentes
catégories finalement tout à fait il ya
cinq catégories donc il ya la catégorie
responsable donc là on est plutôt sur la
responsabilité sociétale
vraiment à la catégorie audace des
femmes qui entreprennent plutôt dans les
milieux habituellement plutôt masculin
on à la partie innovation savoir faire
je crois que je les ai tous dit joe
ricciardi voilà et quartier la dernière
donc là des femmes issues voilà deux
quartiers politique de la ville est
également un sixième le 6e prix c'est un
trophée du public donc avec un vote qui
est mis en place pour élire voilà la
lauréate aura réussi à lever le plus de
le plus de monde sur des réseaux sociaux
nom viendra justement sur le calendrier
de ce concours qu'est ce qu'elle gagne
justement ces lauréates alors il ya des
dotations financières il ya trente mille
euros au total de dotation financière
est parti donc sur les six catégories
également aussi des dotations plus
d'accompagnement ça peut être de
l'accompagnement à la création
d'entreprises sur le leadership sur la
communication et ça peut être aussi donc
il ya air france aussi qu'il ya un des
partenaires du concours qui finance par
exemple un vol long-courrier un aller
retour pour aller faire de la
prospection commerciale à
l'international
c'est pour donner quelques petits
exemples elle justement été lauréate de
créatrice d'avenir en 2020 sophie
fourmaux est artisan d'art et fabrique
des abat jour sur mesure le concours lui
a permis de développer son activité elle
est installée aujourd'hui à voisins le
bretonneux elle revient sur son parcours
avec justin brazès pyramidale conique
style imbriquent ou encore hexagonal
sophie fourmaux khrenov près de 300 abat
jours par mois des créations sur mesure
grâce aux quelques 5000 références de
papier japonais ou népal et en sa
possession un client peut venir nous
voir avec un pied et en fonction de la
taille du pied de sa forme je lui ai
proposé différentes formes d'abat jour
et ensuite le client il n'a plus qu'à
choisir le papier qui lui convient
on
[Musique]
là-bas juriste a participé au concours
en 2020 lauréate de la compétition elle
revient sur son parcours c'était une
très bonne expérience parce que du coup
ça permet de mettre à jour son dossier
son business model sa son ambition de
mettre tout à plat et surtout après il
ya donc le fameux pitch affaire devant
une trentaine de jury on a un pitch
affaires de 7 minutes et ensuite il ya
sept minutes de questions donc c'est une
expérience que je ne connaissais pas
avant mais j'ai appris à le faire avec
créatrice d'avenir sophie fait toujours
partie du réseau créatrice d'avenir elle
souhaitait accroître son entreprise et
l'expérience a porté ses fruits ça m'a
apporté énormément de notoriété de la
crédibilité à mon projet pour trouver
des financements est également ça m'a
apporté du business ça a permis d'avoir
une forte augmentation du chiffre
d'affaires grâce à ce concours suite au
concours l'activité de l'abat-jour east
s'est développée aujourd'hui elle est
accompagnée d'une apprentie pour le côté
commercial à qui elle transmet les
ficelles du métier une ligne de
bagagerie week end arrivera en 2022
comprenant sac est rousse
il nous l'avions donc rencontré en
décembre dernier lorsqu'elle avait été
lauréate de ce concours on les retrouve
retourner la voir et on a vu que les
choses avaient évolué positivement ça
veut dire que créatrice d'avenir ça
donne un coup de pouce non négligeable
assez entrepreneuse oui tout à fait pour
parler du cas de sophie fourny qu'on a
accompagné donc au sein d' initiative
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça lui a
apporté une vraie notoriété et du
business comme elle a pu le dire et qui
lui a permis de pouvoir évoluer et de
transformer enfin son activité cérébrale
était artisan d'art redire tout seul
dans son équipe et puis maintenant
d'aller voilà elle va avoir commencé à
gérer une équipe à l'agrandissent locaux
et voilà le voeu passé voilà de
l'artisan d'art et une petite
manufacture d'abat-jour justement la
création quel est le bilan de ce
concours combien de femmes ont pu être
accompagné grâce à ce concours on a eu
deux mille six cents à peu près projet
de personnes qu'on candidater au
concours et on a six lauréates par année
donc ça sera la onzième année pour
l'instant de 60 lauréate donc il fait
partie d'ailleurs d'un club d'un réseau
et qui continue d'ailleurs de participer
au fur et à mesure de leur évolution
d'entreprise au sein du concours avec
plusieurs histoires dont celle de sophie
forme aussi vous avez des belles
histoires peut-être qu'ils se sont créés
grâce à la créatrice d'avenir lui reste
à faire nous avons fatimata kahn qui a
créé une entreprise de nettoyage en 2013
qui est le concours lui apporter un réel
business et maintenant d'ailleurs elle
rend la pareille c'est à dire qu'elle
fait partie en tant que membre et jury
du concours pour donner aussi ses
conseils et aux futurs entrepreneurs de
belles histoires qui se crée grâce à ce
concours alors pour terminer le
calendrier vous l'avez dit c'est ouvert
les candidatures sont ouvertes jusqu'au
30 septembre que se passe-t-il ensuite
concrètement alors donc jusqu'au 30
septembre les candidates peuvent
postuler donc en ligne sur le site
créatrice d'avenir point com ensuite il
y aura un jury départemental qui va
sélectionner deux finalistes par
catégorie et ensuite ces deux finalistes
de tous les départements vont se
retrouver sur une finale régionale qui
va de sélectionner les 15 finalistes et
les 15 finalistes seront auditionnés
elles seront elles apprendront à peach
et comme a pu le dire se fait fort mais
il est ensuite à l'issue de ces quinze
finalistes il y aura un vote du public
donc on a parlé donc le vote du réseau
quand aura lieu courant novembre et il y
aura les cinq finalistes de chaque
catégorie qui seront qui seront élues
parmi un jury et devant lequel a devront
pitch et vous savez sont désignés par le
jury vous le dites il ya un sixième
lauréate elle elle est choisie par le
public ça serait ça s'appelle le trophée
du public avec un relais sur sur les
réseaux sociaux cette année une
cérémonie en présentiel parce que
l'année dernière c'est vrai que c'est en
visio il me semble à la cérémonie et a
forcément adaptés aux conditions
sanitaires on espère effectivement voilà
au présentiel en fonction des conditions
sanitaires de ce qu'on pourra faire vous
l'avez rappelé déjà mais comment on
candidate pour ce concours en ligne sur
le site créatrice d'avenir point com
voilà c'est un formulaire à compléter et
ci a besoin des deux n'hésitez pas à
vous rapprocher des plates formes
initiative douala de votre territoire
sur les yvelines il y en a deux
initiatives 51 les initiatives seine
yvelines et on est vraiment à votre
disposition on le rappelle un
candidatures qui sont ouvertes jusqu'au
30 septembre prochain merci c'est une
roue d'être venu en plateau et je
rappelle que vous êtes la responsable
d'initiative soixante dix huit ans
toutes les informations vous les avez vu
s'afficher vous l'avez vu s'afficher sur
le site internet de créatrice d'avenir
[Musique]
et dans un instant à suivre le reportage
avec sophie cluzel qui était en visite
c'est ce matin dans les yvelines auprès
de deux unités 1 qui travaillent avec
des enfants en situation de handicap
mais en attendant à ce reportage
direction versailles avec le quintuple
champion du monde de natation camille
lacourt un qui est venu donner une
conférence auprès du réseau de
dirigeants yvelines business club
l'occasion pour lui de partager
également à son expérience de haut
niveau et c'était au micro de michael et
demi d'euros
c'est l'un des plus beaux palmarès de la
natation française camille lacourt était
ce mardi 7 septembre au golf de la
boulie à versailles les sportifs est
venu partager son expérience auprès
d'évelyne business club à un réseau de
dirigeants un univers dans lequel il
s'est plongé après sa retraite en 2017
qu'est ce que je vais leur dire je vais
leur dire ce que moi j'ai fait bien ce
que j'aurais pu faire de mieux ce que
j'ai fait de moins bien est ce que
j'aurais dû faire bien et après voilà en
essayant de leur donner des clés pour la
gestion du stress sur les objectifs sur
sur la compétitivité et après à eux deux
d'essayer de prendre quelques éléments
pour pas pour essayer de les mettre dans
leur entreprise pendant ce rendez-vous
le sportif de deux mètres a raconté son
parcours professionnel ses exploits dans
les différentes piscines du monde la
route a été belle le chemin était à a
été semée d'embûches mais de d'émotion
extraordinaire avec des gens
extraordinaires des coach des
préparateurs mentaux des préparateurs
physiques des kinés pour rencontrer l'ex
sportif de 36 ans le repas affiche
complet j'avais entendu parler de ces
performances si on le voit à la télé
donc
sinon rien de plus c'est une vraie
découverte aujourd'hui camille lacourt
c'est un sportif exceptionnel si
quelqu'un qui a une aura sportive
incroyable tout le monde le connaît
c'est un champion du monde c'est un
champion olympique ça reste quand même
une personne très connue mondialement
c'est un poisson c'est un poisson dans
les bassins est et on a été nombreux à
vibrer autour de ces différentes
victoires camille lacourt a déjà annoncé
vouloir revenir dans les yvelines à
titre privé cette fois ci pour jouer au
golf
dans un instant à suivre je vous le
disais le reportage sur la secrétaire
d'état sophie cluzel en charge du
handicap qui s'est donc rendue ce matin
dans deux établissements des yvelines à
l'objectif c'est se rendre compte de ces
dispositifs mis en place pour les
enfants atteints de handicap c'est un
parcours qui est parfois compliqué aussi
pour les parents et on me dit dans
l'oreillette justement c'est du direct à
que le reportage est arrivé on va le
visionnaire il est proposé par sylvia
gars de son goût de la rédaction de tv
78 ce père de famille a deux enfants
atteints du handicap de l'ataxie de
friedrich cette maladie
neurodégénérative n'a pas été détectée
tout de suite ce qui a posé des
problèmes dans la scolarité de leur
enfant au début l'histoire a commencé
avec des anomalies en dise dyspraxie est
une espèce de d'errance diagnostic au
début des discussions parce que le donc
ça commençait avec antoine qui était en
6e des discussions avec les rares chine
du collège finalement ses deux enfants
ont pu passer leur scolarité dans des
classes dites ordinaires christian
braillard un peu plus tôt dans la
journée à évoquer toutes ces difficultés
notamment le non remboursement des
fauteuils de ses enfants auprès de la
ministre en charge du handicap
celle ci s'est rendu ensuite dans les
yvelines d'abord dans une unité
d'enseignement externalisés dans l'école
des mesnuls cette classe prend en charge
des enfants ayant différents troubles
ici une vraie politique d'économie usine
c'est à dire qu'il ya une classe pour
enfants qui ont des troubles autistiques
et des troubles de comportement des
troubles des fonctions cognitives
totalement inclus dans cette classe ici
avec une volonté du maire des élus
i présent de l'éducation nationale de l'
agence régionale de santé de
l'association des tout petits qui gère
justement cet accompagnement de faire
une réalité de cette école inclusive
dans cette classe seulement six élèves
et l'enseignant t présente seulement à
mi temps l'objectif ici est donc
d'ouvrir une seconde classe la prise en
charge des élèves atteints de handicaps
se fait jusqu'au lycée sophie cluzel
s'est donc rendu ensuite au lycée jean
monnet à la queue-lez-yvelines dans une
classe qui accueille des enfants en
situation de handicap
l'équipe éducative a pu expliquer ce
qu'est la mise en place pour le
bien-être des élèves on a des aides en
situation de handicap qui font partie du
ludisme unité localisée pour l'inclusion
scolaire ces élèves viennent en cours et
son
sont dans leur classe 2
dans leur place de classes classiques
ils viennent nous a lu lice pour revoir
les cours pour préparer les cours selon
la ministre en charge du handicap cent
mille enfants handicapés de plus sont
scolarisés depuis quatre ans
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi demain vendredi même
heure place aux 7,8 week-end de
l'actualité mais aussi aient des idées
de sorties pour bien terminer la semaine
dans les yvelines le journal lui revient
à lundi et vous avez rendez vous avec
justin brasier belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]